dur
m
vous savez où nous sommes
nous sommes à beaublanc nous sommes des
forêts bois de couleurs et cette
euphorie fait 1500 hectares ici c'est la
coulisse à 17,38 aujourd'hui cette forêt
il rogne et les forêts vierges que nous
nature morte aux boîtes grand par voie
de papaye n'a le bombo flotte bon bout à
l'autre en trombe donnant le bain juin
onana le bois pêche endémiques de l'île
maurice et la réunion
apprenant le bois blancs le bois blancs
disparition aussi pour le bonheur de 50
pieds en bois blond et saint-philippe un
symbole il a arrêté par le gouvernement
tout ça ramène pas rationnel c'est un
bois faut protéger il dit avant jeudi
ciel
gecina sans grands dégâts de prendre
sous peu s'il s'est sauvé amont les
jeunes j'ai dit c'est que le bois blancs
m
monsieur diop et trouve pour lynda lemay
lp1 le napt le pape en voilà lemoine au
tec tec plus chaque watt 16es de la
vierge des passages de l'allier n'a
beaucoup ici et c'est au moment où il
vient d'un nouveau loisir un avis est
bonne mais nate elle a beaucoup de
mainates ici à bois blanc ce moment
c'est une affaire les protégés barème
mais elle met la voirie l'otan entend le
mail pays ça n'a fait les protéger si
pour l'instant que c'est un coup à les
respecter
funny voir qu'on écoute et voilà c'est
donc assez
belle occasion travailler ici jusqu'à
les mots cola est planté des fichiers
pouvoir tout seul effet de la main les
pas duré près de machines petit bichon
qu'avec un bon ancien moulin neuf et
apam a donné quand tu es fini c'est un
là le bois la repasser sa nef repas
c'est qu'en général est la ville où est
sa place à s'habiller tout mon temps à
avoir mon les plantes est tout simple
antenne la main s'ils travaillent
l'effet de la montée à 100 personnes
et c'est un peu mon patrimoine bras mais
c'est un jour phinney karajan dames 1
sainte-rose gère le ms de bois blanc
depuis 2007
il s'agit d'un massif forestier de 1500
hectares s'étend donc ici sur les hauts
du village de bois blanc avec trois
grandes propriétés première de 290
hectares une deuxième de 860 et une
troisième de 360 et a la particularité
donc ici sur le site de bois blanc ce
que nous étions vraiment sur les flancs
du piton de la fournaise et donc nous
avons un site très lié volcanisme actif
récent c'est à dire sur ce site que nous
avons là coulées volcaniques de 1977
donc pour les très récentes sur laquelle
nous pouvons montrer la colonisation
végétales des laves ce qui est une
particularité au sein des années dans le
réseau dns à la réunion d'autre part
nous avons aussi le bois blancs qui est
à une espèce particulière espèces
endémiques et très rare donc qui a donné
son nom à la localité du village et
allen est donc de bois blancs donc nous
pouvons aussi montré au public cette
espèce et puis raconter l'histoire de ce
site de ce lieu son histoire naturelle
on y sera agricole sur une histoire liée
aux populations qui ont vécu ici
donc comme je vous parle du massif
forestier de bois blancs nous sommes
si dans un paysage très particulier avec
la coexistence de plusieurs grands
témoignages tirés de l'histoire
volcanique la fournaise juste
derrière nous nous avons un rempart
d'effondrement qui datent de faire
rentrer milan qui est
témoignage de l'effondrement du piton de
la fournaise donc dans son évolution jeu
sa cote est donc je vous disais pendant
une coulée de 40 ans à peu près une
coudée qu'il met en place en 1977
aujourd'hui la commune apporte ici l'on
gagne un travail régulier en termes
d'entretien en terme d'accueil du public
nous accueillons régulièrement des
enfants des classes des associations il
ya aussi un public qui fréquente le site
de manière spontanée des habitants du
village qui se promènent qui font de la
randonnée sur le site et donc c'est un
site avec un gros potentiel
environnemental un site intéressant et
riche qui complète je dirais les
meetings et des années sur le niveau
niveau du département